$322 may not seem like a lot but you'd
be surprised when an enterprising dota2
fan could buy 80 copies of
darude-sandstorm EP a single Sennheiser
PC 350 headset perfect for throwing 53
yards of Hellmann's mayonnaise or 216
large mango iced frog's favorite dota
but would you risk an eSports career for
any of it that's what happened in the
three-to-two incident and though it
wasn't the first case of match fixing in
esports it was the first type profile
case for dota 2 and it's since become
shorthand for any play that seems
suspiciously bad TV boomer Auto Tech the
rain she's gonna dive the tower that
might actually die for this I'm end up
giving up probably since I don't do it
don't do it sire Tiago who want to eat
jelly lucky hit it was mid 2013 and the
sixth season of starseries was winding
down rox.kis would end their
unsuccessful campaign with a match again
Z raised on the final day of the
round-robin no matter who won the result
wouldn't affect the standard but the
outcome was pretty bizarre the heavily
favored rock squad lost 2-0 aged in a 27
minute
slaughter fest that included a lot of
bad decision-making in the form of
astoundingly terrible engagement it's
Benzema we were very lucky it was
reasonably solo as well they just want
in here to die what's in this Aspen I
don't want to say it's impossible for
our comeback but Yolo
and my mama no trust and very
ill-advised buybacks by wrong bzz he
came back cross himself into an ice bath
there comes a two second son and that's
going to be this [__] on the
sidelines to put it in perspective
Rox gave up 50 till that game that's
nearly to a minute to a minute maybe I
mean keeping up on current events we
just got our asses kicked pal it could
have been just a case of a team clowning
during a meaningless game a concept
that's not exactly uncommon for dota 2 I
mean then again this game does not
matter for liquid so maybe maybe they
want you to give me in the final in the
playoffs but evidence surfaced that
rox.kis player Alexei Solo Berezin had
bet against his team with the odds so
firmly in his team's favor the bet would
turn $100 and a loss into 322 starladder
banned solo from their events for life
issued three year bans to his teammates
and banned the rocks organization for a
year rocks initially defended the team
saying that the evidence was
inconclusive but the player eventually
admitted that he had placed the bet and
rocks apologized at solo left the roster
starladder then commuted solos van to a
year as far as we know solo never got
the money have mercy on your stalling on
that part of the curse so that's where
the 3-2 to number comes from but how has
it been used since that time well in
game or in Twitter chat it's now
basically shorthand for any play that
it's bad enough to be
I was the jump on the tail vertebra need
to keep a certain force is the shield
emmechelle ball look back 5 HP and the
cat well as one of his nine lives that
was so greedy but why did he do that
when used outside of the game a
three-to-two simply refers to
match-fixing the meme is so widely
accepted by the community that when Aero
gaming was removed from the summit - by
organisers even their team management
referred to the accusations against two
of their players as a three-to-two
scandal in our current era of esports
throwing a game for $322 seems pretty
ridiculous but valve took the matter
seriously and according to a Facebook
post by former team Titan manager
Tiffany Olin Lim
they held a briefing at the
International floor which clearly stated
that match fixers would be banned from
valve events correctly this set the tone
for the future of dota 2 esports and
underscored the fact that future match
Victor's would not receive the leniency
that solo had asked for solos career he
managed to bounce back despite the
incident now a number of virtus Pro who
recently won dota some at 7 and came
second at the TF major the ban is
comfortably in the rearview mirror but
the mean as it so often does remain guy
rat who Hey Dude want an easy way to
make $322
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]